what is it
what's what that pulling the carriage
nothing's pulling the carriage harry
it's pulling itself like always
[Music]
you're not going mad
i can see them too
you're just as sane as i am
[Applause]
[Music]
let's get ready to learn english with
the enchanting luna lovegood so i've
loved the harry potter film and book
series since i was a child
besides the magic and adventure what i
loved the most was the incredible
characters in this story
and if you're a fan of the series then
you will definitely agree that luna
lovegood is without a doubt one of the
most beloved characters now not only is
she quirky witty and wise but she is
also one of the most unique characters
that you encounter so in this lesson
you'll learn tons of great vocabulary
while we look at some of the reasons
that make luna love good so special but
before we do if you'd like to understand
your favorite tv series and movies
without getting lost without missing the
jokes and without subtitles then be sure
to hit that subscribe button and the
bell end below so that you never miss
out on one of our new lessons
[Music]
now this first scene is where some of
the characters are introduced to luna
for the first time let's have a look
hi guys
what is it
what's what that pulling the carriage
nothing's pulling the carriage harry
it's pulling itself like always
[Music]
you're not going mad
i can see them too
you're just as sane as i am
everyone says
luna love good
what an interesting necklace
it's a charm actually
it keeps away the nargles
hungry
i hope there's pudding
no idea
[Music]
what is it
what's what that pulling the carriage
a carriage is an old-fashioned vehicle
usually for a small number of passengers
which is pulled by horses in british
english a carriage is also one of the
separate long sections of a train that
carries passengers in the us we call
this a train car or rail car
um it's prince charming you should just
know well your prince sherman isn't
going to rescue you in a horse and carry
so that's not who you want
you're not going mad
here the word mad refers to someone who
is mentally ill or losing their ability
to think in a normal way
so luna is telling harry that what he
has seen is real and that he's not
losing his mind however the word mad has
multiple meanings you can use mad to
describe people or things that you think
are very foolish example you'd be mad to
go outside in this weather
you can use mad to mean that someone is
very angry example she's mad at me
because i don't want to go with her
if you are mad about something or
someone you like them very much example
he's mad about you
mad behavior is wild and uncontrolled
example the audience went mad when the
band walked on stage
you're just as sane as i am
we use the word sane to describe someone
who can think reasonably and does not
have a mental illness this sentence is
humorous because when luna tells harry
that he is just the same as she is she
actually seems a bit strange as she is
reading a magazine upside down and also
given the not so kind nickname other
students have given luna everyone this
is really love
luna lovegood
did you notice how hermione paused after
she said looney love we would say that
she had a slip of the tongue which is an
expression you can use when someone says
something by accident when they intended
to say something else this means that
hermione did not mean to reveal the
nickname loony lovegood loony is an
offensive word that means someone is
insane foolish or strange
although luna's behavior is somewhat
unusual she is certainly not insane we
can see an example of her lovable
quirkiness in this scene
i've never been to this part of the
castle
at least not while awake i sleepwalk you
see
that's why i wear shoes to bed
some fans even say that their favorite
thing about luna is that she is a
non-conformist which means that she
doesn't try to be anything other than
who she truly is
who is your favorite harry potter
character let us know down in the
comments below and we might just make a
lesson with them
it's a charm actually
the word a charm also has several
meanings
a small object which is worn on a chain
is jewelry
an object that is thought to have
magical powers such as the ability to
bring good luck
both of these could apply to what luna
says also if you say that something
works like a charm you mean that it was
very effective or successful example
when i was sick this medicine worked
like a charm
another example of a magic item that
luna is known for is her iconic spectre
specs glasses that supposedly allow the
wearer to see rack spurts which are
invisible creatures that float through
your ears and make your brain go fuzzy
let's have a look at them
hello harry luna how do you know where i
was oxford
your head's full of them
keeps away the nargles
nargles are magical creatures that live
in mistletoe unfortunately luna is the
only character in the series who
believes in their existence
your feet
are like cold
unfortunately all my shoes have
mysteriously disappeared
i suspect gnargles are behind it
hungry
i hope there's pudding
in the uk pudding is usually a sweet hot
dish made with pastry flour bread or
rice and often fruit however in the us
pudding is a sweet soft food made from
milk sugar eggs and flavoring eaten cold
hey do you want to be able to watch
absolutely any movie or tv series in
english without needing subtitles if
understanding the jokes the culture and
every word is important to you then our
free three-part masterclass is just what
you need to speak english more
confidently and naturally
simply sign up now by clicking up here
or down the description below
[Music]
now although luna's unique and unusual
behavior is what most of us love about
her character she is one of the most
important characters from ravenclaw the
house of the wise and intelligent and of
course she is also very wise and has a
kind heart which we will see in this
scene
[Music]
how come you're not at the feast
lost all my professions
apparently people have been hiding them
that's awful oh it's all good fun
but as is the last night i really do
need them back
do you want any help finding them
i'm sorry about your godfather harry
are you sure you don't any are looking
that's all right
anyway
my mom always said the things we lose
have a way of coming back to us in the
end
if not always in the way we expect
[Music]
i think i'll just go have some pudding
[Music]
how come you're not at the feast
a feast is a large and special meal
usually eaten during a celebration such
as a wedding or party before we begin
the feast
[Music]
let us have a round of applause
for professor sprout
madame pumphrey the feast is also a verb
which means to enjoy eating a large
amount of food why do you struggle so
against your true nature
let's feast together like we've always
dreamed
last on my possessions
we use the word possessions to refer to
anything we own
that doesn't even show if it not every
single possession every memory
everything you've had your whole life
gone in a second can you imagine what
that must feel like
i'm sorry about your godfather harry
godparents are important in some
cultures and religions and generally
they are people chosen by the parents to
take care of the child should anything
happen to the parents
before they died harry's parents lily
and james potter asked sirius to be
harry's godfather so that harry would be
taken care of if anything happened to
them later series was also killed so
this is a tragic time for harry we can
say that harry is grieving or mourning
which means the behavior where someone
shows sadness about a person's death
here luna is sympathizing with harry
which means to show someone who is in
bad situation that you are sorry for
them that you care and that you
understand their situation she is also
very empathetic which means that she is
understanding and considerate of other
people's feelings here is a great
example of that
hello harry
i've interrupted a deep thought haven't
i
can see it growing smaller in your eyes
of course not how are you luna very well
got bitten by a garden known only
moments ago gnome saliva is very
beneficial centerfield is love good we
live just over the head nice to meet you
sir come daddy harry doesn't want to
talk to us right now it's just too
polite to say that
anyway
my mom always said the things we lose
have a way of coming back to us in the
end
[Music]
if not always in the way we expect
here we see a great example of luna's
wisdom as this line has become one of
the most famous quotes in the series on
the one hand she might be talking about
her lost sneakers but on the other hand
by both her and harry's facial
expressions it appears she meant
something more because they both lost
their most important people in their
life her mom and his parents and
godfather
alright now let's do a quick quiz to see
how much you've learned by watching
without subtitles and answering some
quiz questions
[Music]
hi guys
what is it
what's what that pulling the carriage
nothing's pulling the carriage harry
it's pulling itself like always
[Music]
you're not going mad
which of these is similar to mad
doubtful
crazy
curious
[Music]
i can see them too
you're just as sane as i am
everyone this is lonely love
luna love good
what an interesting necklace
it's a charm actually
it keeps away the nargles
hungry
i hope there's pudding pudding usually
tastes
sour
salty
sweet
[Music]
no idea
how come you're not at the feast
lost all my professions
apparently people have been hiding them
that's awful oh it's all good fun
but as the last night i really do need
them back
do you want any help finding them
i'm sorry about your godfather harry
what is another word for feeling sad
after someone dies
grieving
insane
mourning
[Music]
are you sure you don't want any help
looking that's all right
anyway
my mom always said the things we lose
have a way of coming back to us in the
end
if not always in the way we expect
[Music]
i think i'll just go have some pudding
[Music]
all right if you enjoyed this lesson and
you'd like to continue learning with
harry potter then be sure to check out
this lesson with the recent harry potter
reunion let's check out a clip from that
i wouldn't be the person i am without so
many people here
it's a very overwhelming thing because
i've watched you grow up and i've seen
kind of every stage of your life
when things get really dark and times
are really hard there's something about
harry potter that makes life richer it's
a strong bond that we'll always have
we're family and we will always be part
of each other's life